[Music]
[Applause]
let bring in Eli Manning who joins us on
the program were you recruited by
crabber state I didn't get a letter from
them unfortunately but would would have
been a strong consideration
though um when you look back on
recruiting was there anything that stood
out that was like interesting different
bizarre um well you know Mike Leech was
at Kentucky and he was the one that um
recruited me hard and honestly I'd be on
the phone I wouldn't say a word for an
hour like he would just go and he would
just I he was no different than what he
was all his coaches got rest of his soul
but just one of the great personalities
and he he could talk like no one I've
ever seen I'd be I'd be like looking at
my dad like I gotta get off the phone I
got some homework to do like I got some
stuff to do I can't get a word in um but
he was uh he was he was always
interesting kind of going on his on his
spats about who knows what but how close
was it that you were going to go to
Kentucky um you know they were they were
throwing it around and it was how Mommy
and and they you know Tim Couch was you
know in the mix and they were they were
kind of having some upset so if you
wanted to go throw it around and do the
spread offense and and have some fun
that was a spot so I don't I don't know
if it was you know it wasn't totally uh
outside the mix but it wasn't it wasn't
in the top 10 if you were coming out
now what would Intrigue you where would
Intrigue you I mean I think uh I think
there's a lot of lot of schools that are
intriguing I mean obviously I mean
Georgia Alabama are always in the mix in
in the SEC old miss you know Lane kein
they're throwing it they're you know
putting up a lot of points offensively
Ohio State's always in the mix I mean
you kind of look at the top teams um
consistent ly I think those are always
popular but I think it's still important
for for players to hey look at who's the
offensive coordinator who's the
quarterback coach who's the head coach
uh what What's the vibe of of the team
and the closeness of everybody so I
think it's it's really about you know
taking those visits being around the
players being around the coaches and
where do you feel comfortable where do
you feel hey I'm not a fit in here I'm
going to be happy here and also look at
the University I think it was important
to me and I think it's because I had an
old brother Cooper who went to play
college football and got injured and
never played a down I said hey I want to
pick a school where if something happens
and I never played one down of football
I'm G to be happy here and I'm going to
stay here and this is where I want to be
and now I don't know if that's that's
going into any consideration with with
uh with guys now and and or any any you
know athlete is where they pick their
school it's nil and it's you know it's
so easy to transfer I don't know if
that's a that's a part of their decision
making what's the biggest mistake
mistake we make or analysts make looking
at a college quarterback when he goes to
the NFL that we see success in college
but what do we miss out on most do you
think um I think it's I think it's just
it's got to be you know how how you know
how is the guy getting the ball out um
you know on time in Rhythm and I think
that's something that it doesn't you
know it doesn't it's hard to see that in
college like hey how many times is is he
you know not looking at the right place
going you know looking at the wrong read
hey he can scramble he can create plays
but he's holding it you know for four
seconds and got the ball got the
completion that just doesn't happen in
the NFL I think it's you know looking
hey is this guy getting the ball out on
time in Rhythm throwing the ball
accurately into you know on on time is
is just so important and I think it's
hard to hard to get a sense of that in
college you you you can hold the ball
longer it's hard to get pressure on the
quarterback unless they're blitzing with
a fourman rush you know the quarterback
can sit back there three and a half
seconds and that just that doesn't
happen in the NFL he's Eli Manning
two-time Super Bowl champ uh do we want
to play Guess Eli Manning's middle name
we could play that okay around the room
you want to go first or last Todd you go
first Dabney Dabney okay okay all right
C I'm gonna say I'm gonna say Whitney
Whitney Eli Whitney Eli Whitney
I like that I like it Marvin I'm going
go Nathaniel
Nathaniel okay strong Paulie I know it
so I can give you a hint Dan before you
guess his older brother Payton's his
middle name is Williams okay I was going
to go Winston Eli Winston Manning Jr
II what is it it's Nelson Nathaniel was
close Nelson which is a family name
named after kind of one of my my uncles
uh so yeah Elijah Elijah Nelson Manning
strong name uh you're joining us on
behalf of Quaker their uh preg Green
tour I'll let you give the pitch here
yeah that's uh kicking off the first
ever Quaker preg grain tour if you don't
know what preg graining is it's
basically you just start your pregame
with some Quaker Oats which I did every
day and and still do and so basically
this is a tailgate visiting NFL stadiums
throughout this year they've had a few
got a few more and they're introducing
their new digital Quaker Playbook which
is 32 recipes representing all the NFL
teams and that tour will end at the
Super Bowl Taste of the NFL well they'll
announce a
$250,000 uh donation to Quaker's
longtime partner Jin youth uh which is a
a youth Wellness uh nutrition
organization nonprofit and so it's
really about what Quaker's doing and
understanding that the circumstances of
life should not be a barrier for good
nutrition so it's uh great to team up
with them have a little fun do some
tailgating and you know learn some
different recipes for using Quaker Oats
pton famously had Omaha Omaha did you
feel like you had to be creative at all
with any of your audible calls well
first off I think we got to set the
record straight we're I used Omaha way
before Peyton ever used it he sto it wow
that's breaking news
it is breaking news so that's
intellectual property that he stole from
you yes exactly it was in our Playbook
it was a word uh he used it the exact
same way and I but I have to be a little
honest I not me personally but um my
rookie season uh John huffnagel our
offensive coordinator he come from New
England and he brought it from New
England so I stole it technically from
Tom Brady we used it for a long time
and then 200 I guess
15ish I think that's the year they must
have really turned up the microphones on
the quarterback they put the speaker
they put the recording on on our Jersey
so you could hear everything the
quarterback was saying and and Peyton
played a playoff game and he must have
sent Omaha 85 times in the game and it
just you know everybody's like what is
going on what is the big deal about
Omaha he's getting free Stakes out of
this got a key to the city
he's got a production company named
after it and like he I get nothing he
didn't send me a steak I don't get I get
nothing from no no credit whatsoever
when do you know that you've pressed the
button maybe too strongly with Payton
like you'll you'll
jab but when do you know that you cross
the line when he doesn't respond he just
kind of like he he kind of just goes
quiet and just kind of shakes his head a
little bit like hey that's off limits
don't go don't don't keep going don't
harp on that don't expand on that like
you're you're in you're in dangerous
territory you know Retreat a little bit
Retreat so when he he kind of just he
does not you know respond to it that's
the forehead gets red I think when
that's kind of it's kind of always the
case that's a big forehead it is it is
when the vein the vein starts coming in
the neck and like on the side of the
forehead right there it's like looks
that's that's more clock
management situations on the opposing
team or one of the teams that's that's
when the vain clock management is his
number one pet peeve if I were ever say
I don't think Peyton had good clock
management as a quarterback I think he
would he Burst Into You Know Flames uh
great to talk to you good luck with a
Quaker pregra tour he's Eli Nelson
Manning III Elijah Elijah Nelson Elijah
Nelson Manning Jr II good to talk to Eli
thank you thanks Dad all right Eli
Manning there